originally created by a visionary game
developer Shigeru Miyamoto Mario games
have been one of the most successful
franchises in the video game medium with
titles still being made today and
origins stretching back to the very
early arcade games in the past few years
countless people have asked me to make a
video on the symbolism of this or that
video game usually those with exhausts
of mythology's like Warhammer or elder
scrolls
however by looking at the structure of
the early arcade mario games and then
moving to Super Mario Brothers we will
be able to unlock the most basic
elements of video game symbolism and how
it connects the universal patterns
hopefully this will give all of you a
few keys for looking into other games as
well
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
our best games endure through time
because their microcosms and ritualized
versions of some basic pattern of
reality they permit us to engage with
the structure of the world whether it be
hierarchy and upward and downward
movement like chutes and ladders
competition and war like chests or team
sports or the excitement and surprise of
fortune like dice or card games while in
our lives war is bloody costly and
destructive chess and football provide a
boiled down ritualized experience and
practice of the same pattern without the
egregious consequences in video games we
experience effort perseverance adversity
and adventure in cycles as world or
levels begin and end were celebrated for
our success and death is most often the
image of our losses there have been
different iterations of Mario from the
early beginnings often marking the
progression of video game through
technical feats and even content
elaboration for this reason these games
are some of the best for discovering a
basic sense of video game symbolism of
course we all mostly came to know Mario
from the classic Super Mario Brothers
but to understand how it all comes
together we need to start with Donkey
Kong
in Donkey Kong a giant King Kong like a
kidnaps your beloved and holds her at
the top of a series of ladders an
obstacle which represent a kind of power
in construction playing is Jumpman the
pre named mario and a regular
construction guy you must ascend to the
top of the level to be joined with her
again this reunion is short-lived as
when you reach the top the ax grabs her
and ascends higher up the tower each of
these a sense leaves you at the bottom
of the next level where you must climb
again to reach or once more arriving at
the very top of the tower the final
level consists in removing the studs
from the tower so that the APUs cast
down and you can be finally united with
your beloved for good now the first
thing to note is this donkey in Donkey
Kong is that it's arguably the first
video game to integrate a clear
progressive narrative of character arts
within the game dynamics themselves
although some prior games have had
characters or simulation structures
Donkey Kong had a clear character
relationship and a story progression
it's one of the most simple yet mythic
story structures of course ascending
through levels and trials to save the
girl the idea of the unattainable
feminine has been a narrative pattern
and a motivation for human improvement
since the medieval chivalric code
according to late medieval thinking
desiring and reaching a worthy feminine
character pulls the hero into an
adventure that makes him a better
version of himself in this case the muse
or the heavenly feminine appears as a
stand-in for the game itself and its
resolution as you master the game in
order to win that is as you become a
better player the ideal of the game just
like your ideal feminine keeps getting
pulled higher and higher the game gets
harder but the value of attaining your
beloved increases as well we can see
that in a very crude form by ascending a
tower Donkey Kong followed the same
pattern as Dante's ascent up the
heavenly spheres in his Divine Comedy
there his beloved Beatrice guides him up
from the mountain as yet
hell and purgatory as Dante reaches the
highest fears Beatrice is transformed
into the highest feminine ideal the very
mother of god herself Mary now all human
efforts to attain a goal appear in two
aspects a negative and a positive a
difficulty and a prize
the positive aspect the prize is the
hitting of a mark or the reaching of a
summit and it's also the coming together
of everything whether it's writing a
paper delivering a project or making a
cake reaching a goal is always a
communion of priorly disparate elements
and this is why it is most suitably
represented by love and the union of the
masculine and feminine this is of course
where the kiss or the marriage so often
accompanies the resolution of our
popular stories the negative aspect in
the path to attain a goal can take many
forms a puzzle to be solved an obstacle
to be overtaken a confusion which needs
to be made clear a chaos that needs to
be organized the negative aspect can
also appear as an inward quest to master
and order your activities honing chaotic
potential to accomplish a new skill on
an even more psychological level the
obstacle can be our disordered passions
the lack of discipline lack of focus
which needs to be tamed in order to
succeed in anything and so each screamed
each level of the game and ultimately
the whole game itself appears as an
obstacle a puzzle to overcome a skill to
be mastered while also containing the
boon or the satisfaction which comes
from attaining the goal in solving the
problem so the game cycles you over and
over within each screen of the game
until you master it that is why the top
of each screen is represented by both an
obstacle a kind of barrier a guardian
but in video game jargon will later be
called a level boss and the prize which
is the escape and the liberation of the
current level the very reaching of a
higher level of the game a level closer
to the resolution of the entire pattern
you die over and over fail over and over
until you escape the level you're in a
kind of micro samsara you go through all
the screens until you transcend the
whole pattern with the fall of Donkey
Kong in this manner doc
a monstrous giant appears as the
guardian of a mystery the union with the
beloved but also just the mystery of the
next level in the game and the
possibility of reaching higher on the
tower
Donkey Kong even taunts you with a
little cutscene we see this pattern in
so many of the ancient stories from the
giant in Jack and the Beanstalk who
guards the gold and the singing harp two
trolls blocking bridges to even more
ancient stories of the Sphinx who blocks
the road and whose riddle must be solved
so it does not devour you
the ultimate example in our culture
would be the cherub which guards the
Garden of Eden or guarding the Holy of
Holies of the temple it's also the image
of the ascent of a spiritual ladder
which appears in much religious imagery
the attaining of virtue or higher states
of being as a ladder whose levels can be
represented by the duality of a dark and
a light figure a demon and an angel a
way to ascend and a way to descend but
one does not have to be so esoteric to
see the pattern it's also the pattern of
going to school where you know each
grade level must be finished by
mastering your skills accumulating
points and beating a test so that you
don't have to be held back and repeat
the year again but rather you can ascend
to the next grade where the problems
become harder and the prestige of
succeeding increases as well like I said
the video game is a highly ritualized
participation in cosmic patterns I
talked a bit earlier about a kind of
micro samsara in this game and so it's
important to mention that even when you
finish the basic narrative pattern of
the game which ends with the fall of
Donkey Kong the game starts over faster
and harder at another level making each
narrative cycle more prestigious to
finish the fractal pattern of screens
could have been indefinite if it was not
for a strange glitch in the game
programming what is known as the Donkey
Kong kill screen there's a Donkey Kong
kill screen coming up which stops you
from going further and causes Mario to
die after four seconds glitches are
actually extremely important in
understanding the medicine
we could say of video games but we'll
look at that in our next video when we
talk about super mario brothers because
Donkey Kong is a love story within the
narrative of Donkey Kong we also find an
example and a counter example of the
proper union of different elements in
love Donkey Kong
represents the brutish Beast Lee aspect
of the person maybe the dark aspect of
Mario himself he's the hairy garment of
skin the Dionysian embodiment of wild
strength and abandoned to desire the
reference of the donkey or the ass is
supposed to mark Donkey Kong as a
stubborn brute like Mario Donkey Kong
also desires the beloved but his animal
abandon makes him take her by force
guard her jealously and unleashes
destructive power on the structures of
civilization he makes things crooked
throws barrels and leashes flames and
all these other obstacles Mario is the
Apollonian builder or fixer when
mastering the game and overcoming Donkey
Kong demonstrates directed desire you
know worked out with method and honed
skill like I said by mastering the game
Mario and the player are making
themselves worthy of receiving the boon
and being united to the beloved once the
final level has been reached the monster
falls on his head all the way down the
tower if he were the devil we would say
that he's been cast into hell and the
final union of the bride and the
bridegroom can occur at the very top of
the tower the relationship between the
wild Dionysian character and the
Apollonian builder can also take on a
different aspect so if in Donkey Kong
Mario must master skills and the monster
to win the girl in the sequel Donkey
Kong jr. we now have the tables flipped
in this game the image of Mario as
civilization builder is shifted to the
negative side of order we see him
appearing as a tyrant who has Cades the
wild animal
[Applause]
[Music]
the son of Donkey Kong must find a
number of keys to open the cage holding
his father in order to free the wild
aspect from hyper order instead of
barrels and oil drums which are subject
to burst into flames
the enemy's mario and leashes are
mechanical otama tongs and birds
emphasizing this excess of order the
game is also in a way a funny version of
the descent into the underworld to save
your father as Kong's cage is said to be
hidden in Mario's hideout somewhere far
away in terms of the game itself the
pattern of freeing the enslaved
passionate creature also manifests one
of the reasons for the video game itself
in contrast to the Builder civilizer
Mario it's a reaffirmation that we are
not robots that our transformation is
meant to bring joy and that the playing
of a game is also meant to be fun and
pleasurable not only the winning of
coins and conquering of levels this is
of course true of any endeavor we
accomplish the image of the football dad
of course will immediately come to mind
if we hyper focus on any goal we run the
risk of destroying the wilder and more
particular aspects of life the spice
which makes us relatable and human as
well so Donkey Kong jr. balances out
Donkey Kong in the end and acts as a
warning not to accept the story only
from one side but returning to Donkey
Kong I want to say one more thing about
the big hairy monster we often imagine
the monsters or Giants as marginal
figures as the Beast of the edge of
society but when we understand the world
of phenomena as an organized hierarchy
we can see why monsters both invade from
outside you know eat you in the forest
but they also guard treasures and
princesses and towers if you live in an
ancient city there are guards on the
outer walls to stop foreign armies from
invading but there's also guards at the
gate of the castle to stop you from
simply waltzing into the throne room
both series of guards play a similar
role preventing outsiders from
said access to what is inside it's just
that in this schema you are also an
outsider to a higher royal reality
Donkey Kong we mostly see the monster as
a guardian and an obstacle to the higher
reality in our more primordial
consideration of monsters though we
often understand them as these dark
things you know the hidden things that
come out of the corners that come up
from the watery depths they can be big
monsters but they can also be pests
critters which need to be taken care of
in this image instead of picturing the
monster above you like an obstacle like
Donkey Kong we need to think of the
monsters below you or outside which
build up like mosquitoes or black flies
they can be the accumulation of little
problems in your life which bubble up
and take over the way that if you don't
get rid of that small line of ants you
see on your floor you will one day maybe
find those ants eating the very walls
that hold your house together if you
don't take care of that leak you'll soon
find your house flooded it is this
structure which is taken up in Mario
Brothers the arcade game
in this game Mario and his brother Luigi
are reframed as plumbers instead of
carpenters instead of going up a tower
to save a girl they're not called down
into the sewers to deal with these pests
that are taking over they encounter
turtles crabs and other monsters which
pop out of the pipes as they clean each
level in order to attain the next level
so by the plumber reference the pests
are in a way related to a leak which
must be stopped the accumulation of
pests as a rising chaos is also
intuitively related to a flood so in
this game structure we discover the
infamous clean your room scenario touted
by Jordan Peterson clean up your room
okey-dokey this manifests another aspect
of order and civilization not so much
the ascent of a hierarchy but rather the
stabilizing and making square of
identities making clean that which is
dirty or making straight that which is
crooked removing that which could be a
distraction an infection or an
infestation it is as much running the
antivirus on your computer and it is
mowing your lawn or getting rid of some
bad habit and it's the basic
prerequisite to later ascending the
hierarchy when you look at Donkey Kong
and these other games there's a
crudeness to both the design the
gameplay and also even the narrative
these crew tropes like a monster a sexy
girl cages with keys or pests and sewers
appears simplistic and lacking in
subtlety but like other video games or
early comic books
it is rather through a type of innocence
that they manifest a very powerful
pattern the ramifications of the
patterns they engaged with might even
have been unknown to their creators at
the time yet the simple expression
appears in a form that is immediately
accessible to anyone from a
four-year-old to an adult which give
them a kind of universal reach so Donkey
Kong and other early games are formed at
the proper level of innocence and
simplicity to be the origin for a world
these original patterns would be
unpacked slowly but inevitably
through the history of video games
although many recent games have reached
unheard-of levels of sophistication when
when scratches the surface we often find
the same pattern reoccurring a hierarchy
of levels a boss a prize and a
triumphant end what is mostly
fascinating is that if Donkey Kong and
the early Mario games explore cosmic
patterns from many angles the next game
in this series Super Mario Brothers
often hailed as one of the most
successful groundbreaking and best video
games of all time is able to pull many
of these symbolic elements together
while also encompassing other aspects
which make it closer to a full microcosm
including the notion of the secret and
even the ambiguous yet important
narrative function of the mistake or the
glitch so I hope you'll join me in
discovering the world of Super Mario
Brothers in my next video hope you
enjoyed my first attempt at video games
symbolism there will be more to come of
course if you enjoy this type of
symbolic interpretation and what I'm
doing please check out my website the
symbolic WorldCom there you will find
links to all the videos transcripts for
some of the videos also links to the
podcast versions we also now have a
multi-user blog where several excellent
people are doing symbolic
interpretations of different things from
religious symbolism to pop culture and
you'll also find there a way to support
my work as you know when the strange
times I really appreciate the support
that people have been giving me it's
been a way for me to continue what I'm
doing to expand it and to involve other
people as well so thank you for your
attention and I will see you very soon